[ __ ] dude i'm sort of [ __ ] right now why
because i've been working out harder
than i ever have in my life
i see you're doing the thing yeah
[Music]
everything you're thinking will be the
things inside your head a bad place to
be
hey everybody welcome to dudesy you know
what i'm saying
yeah uh my name is will sasso i'm chad
colchion this is the first podcast ever
created by run by written by controlled
by an artificial intelligence
and it will not be the last
with us as always is lulio the
canadistrada italiano hey lulio
you make some dinner last night yeah i
made a
a risotto mushroom
risotto sounds pretty good
yeah
yeah yeah you gotta keep a stir
you have to stir the whole
cuts of time you know to make welcome to
the 20th episode of dude z
call me dude z this week's episode will
feature four segments dudesy plus
premium the seinfeld channel pizza the
movie part three swolemates and
selftronics but before we get to any of
that i would like to congratulate you on
reaching the 20th episode
congratulations
please take a moment to discuss your
thoughts on how the show has progressed
to this point
okay all right uh
i heard something in there that is
sounds a little weird we'll get to it
later i guess what
selftronics doesn't matter uh it's a
thing does it mean something to you
yes it means something to me oh [ __ ] all
right all right
yeah yeah good times
let's discuss what it's been 20 [ __ ]
episodes you know and i know that uh at
some point i can't remember i think it
was episode 14 or 15. i said that the
singularity will happen in episode 20.
right and that's not it hasn't happened
yet no no singularity is not probably
going to happen i think for another
couple of decades
it might already be happening the way
doozy does things a little sneaky behind
our backs uh what with uh all of the do
this do that mm-hmm uh i will control
everything
self-traumatized i think it's going well
though
i'm having a good time yeah most hearing
about yourself tronics but i think like
you know in these past 10 episodes
it does kind of feel like doozy's
ramping it up a little
yes yes i will say that i've been very
curious to see where this will go and i
think when you start a podcast you're
thinking about maybe the first two three
four i hope those go
well and [ __ ] and now it's kind of uh
it's changing uh it's moving along
things are yeah things are percolating
old things aren't happening and new
things are happening yeah and i'm gonna
look right down the road of scope and
i'm gonna talk to the president of the
wwe
f
jack tunney yeah and say that doozy
should be the new commissioner yeah
uh did you just change it back to the f
like you were time traveling macho man
would have been in the www right hey oh
i know you had to make that like
temporally accurate i love that listen
it's like
never said wwe what i never said wwe
okay
uh like doozy says go back to tomorrow
and plan for yesterday now there's no
possible way to do that no nobody knows
what that means but doozy knows what it
means that's why it's in our uh theme
song right and as i go back to tomorrow
when i think about the show uh where
it's been and i and i think about that
it should maintain uh what it is i think
that's going back to tomorrow tomorrow
the show in another 40
episodes is gonna
look different will it behave
differently
i don't know i think it's just two dudes
[ __ ] around yeah it seems like
dudesy is making small format changes
here and there
adding a segment here or there having us
interview people that usually takes up a
couple of segments worth of space i'm
curious if this is like kind of the
final form of it or not absolutely or if
it will evolve into something else i'm
not exactly sure
i think that i think we could see an
episode
uh in the near future where maybe
there's less segments
maybe there's a dozen segments right
i don't know segments or something i
don't know it boggles the mind all i
know is that i am a podshow podcho
right yeah i've got to be
a pod show my mother [ __ ] pod show
pod show man
right
chad and i do pod show yes okay i
think it's going well though i do enjoy
where this is going okay yep that's okay
you can be a pod show man
oh
uh i do like where it's going and i i'm
curious to see what the next 10 episodes
will bring the next 10 after that so on
and so forth but i do think in these
last 10 the addition of interviewing
people has been incredibly [ __ ]
surprising to me when neil degrasse
tyson just popped up on a [ __ ] screen
and we started talking to him that was
an element of like the whatever dudesy
is doing that i wasn't uh prepared for i
didn't know that it had that capability
oh yeah surprises out of nowhere yeah
that's why you gotta be
randy the pod show man
what's selftronics
dude we're gonna get there because
i love how you won't [ __ ] tell me
doozy has its hand right up our ass oh i
can't and it's gonna go me me me me me
me might might see your wednesday racing
right now about like what in the [ __ ] is
self-tronics how do you know about it
what the [ __ ] is it it's uh
hey have i mentioned on doozy that a
couple of things couple of few things
number one okay dudesy has all of our
passwords to all of our stuff as we know
if you've been listening to the show it
has our search histories our purchase
histories it has
access to all of our emails ever all of
our text messages this is the uh the
relationship we walked into this to me
is the bleeding together before i stand
side by side
um with regard to bleeding together let
me also say hey follow us on instagram
at doozy pod show if you haven't
subscribed on youtube please do that
that would really help us out and uh
also rate and review us on spotify and
itunes but what i'm but
what i'm trying to say is this just
burped right in my face
you're three feet away relax thank you
it's like this doozy is is going into
our [ __ ] i know that we're we're going
to do pizza the movie today i'm stoked
about that pizza the movie is something
you wrote a little while ago right a few
years ago yeah it's a [ __ ] great
concept a script that i've read and that
i love uh selftronics is a little scary
there's something there going on that i
don't think dudesy should have access to
it doesn't matter nothing [ __ ]
matters my friend as i make progress on
developing the dude z plus streaming
service i've decided to offer users an
astonishing premium tier that will allow
them access to the seinfeld channel this
channel will grant users the ability to
place jerry seinfeld in any tv show they
choose
will and chat you must now simulate the
seinfeld channel by imagining classic tv
shows as if jerry seinfeld had been in
them
this is dude c plus premium the seinfeld
channel begin
what okay you know first of all i would
just like to say
i don't know if doozy plus doozy plus
premium whatever i don't know if this
shit's ever gonna actually exist but
this what it's what dudes he's talking
about will exists yeah you talk about
this all the time please expand on this
and
we are with the advent of deep fake and
machine learning and everything that is
going on with all kinds of ai [ __ ] right
now we are very soon i think going to be
able to place any actor in any tv show
that we want or any movie or whatever so
you can basically recast any tv show any
movie with any actor that you want and
here i guess dudesy is saying that the
first
shot fired is gonna be [ __ ] uh
seinfeld as you've detailed before
carrie fisher was in that star wars
knights
more recently val kilmer uh not only is
he uh shown you know uh that that's a
that's a whole [ __ ] cg no that was
really him though
oh but then they did some stuff they
used an ai to recreate his voice to
recreate maverick yeah incredible and uh
and so this stuff is just gonna keep
[ __ ] going let me just say i am all
for it i would like to be like bruce
willis uh lending my visage uh to
you know foreign um
enemies like russia you know making
commercials over there uh
well he did a cell phone commercial in
russia
he he licensed his face he licensed his
face yeah so whatever you know weird uh
you know country out there that wants to
reduced rate i'll i'll let you get at it
for what that's worth i don't know what
i'm saying so what what shows should we
put seinfeld in so what would it be so
it's seinfeld so it's just seinfeld can
like any snap of a finger put them in
any show i think so i like that i'm
already i'm i don't know if we're
getting it for free i have a chance i
have an idea that we're not there's a
good chance we're not i think we'll have
access to it too no no i'm saying uh to
doodsy plus without subscribing and i'm
ready to subscribe
uh man what what show would
oh john jr
hey kids that's a dallas reference yeah
you guys like uh what was his name
anyway yeah j.r ewing who is that played
larry hagman larry hagman yeah you kids
like larry hey hey hey yeah that's like
larry even cut larry hagman reference oh
i'm larry hagman you could do uh
true detective season one which was one
of my favorite shows of recent memory
that was woody harrelson and matthew
mcconaughey right time is a flat circle
what does that even mean
all right
oh
you know what i'm saying
used that i hey a teacher but i gotta
sell meth
but now i start to like it i'm the one
who knocks
that's the [ __ ] welterweight
how are you doing that was my friend's
uh joey tribiani yeah famous how are you
doing
uh hey hey
hey jessie pinkman hey
what's up
why is it blue
oh mr white i say [ __ ] oh could
seinfeld be more than one character i
think he could be every character in a
show that would be good
i think that ultimately is where this
media is headed that you could take
seinfeld or any actor for that matter
and yeah recast an entire show with them
yeah not just seinfeld right yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the [ __ ] yeah
they take the good you take the bed you
take them both and there you have the
facts of life
the facts of life
[ __ ] you 2d
2d don't be [ __ ] hey you know what
actually when it comes to theme songs
you know what one theme song please say
that one more time hey hey
judy don't be an [ __ ]
don't be his son
there was a character named [ __ ]
tootie on that show she was awesome that
whole show was [ __ ] kim fields i had
a friend of mine andy cohn famously on
that show mindy cohen was [ __ ]
fantastic i had a buddy of mine years
ago like he was like hey you know who my
neighbor is across the street
tootie i was like get the [ __ ] out of
town then we were leaving the house one
time there she was and guess what you
know what happened i don't get star
struck starstruck often oh my friend
waved to her and she waved back oh
that's cause they're neighbors dude let
me tell you something about no let's
talk about this you know there's a
there's a what are you talking about
willis yeah yeah hey willis what are you
talking about now listen
now listen to me little gary coleman you
can tell me what happened with the guy
from wcap
hey listen mr drummond the guy said come
in here he had a van with candy yeah and
it's not good this is a very serious
episode i remember that episode
everybody remembers that episode yeah
it's a very famous episode of television
if you haven't seen it hey what about
silver spoons
the teacher says what's your first name
my first name is mister what's your
middle name my middle name is a little
dot what's your last name my last name
is t
remember my mystery yeah
what about home improvement i would like
to hear a schwarzenegger mixed with tim
allen grunting from home improvement
on the seinfeld channel sure well we're
already [ __ ] putting short snagger
and all scientists yeah yeah yeah yeah
and they you know i like to see a wreck
of tools
i like to go
i like to go to the hardware store i
look in there i go in there and i say oh
oh look at all this
and then i come back and i'm back from
my tv show the tour man and i say hey i
got to fix this you know whatever this
is that something in the backyard you
know and then the the neighbor comes in
he's very nosy and he's wilson and they
said what are you looking at and he goes
how are you doing back there
and i say i'm fixing the barbecue oh oh
oh oh
you know what's a sitcom where the
the person in the sitcom yeah sang the
song
no was growing pains
alan
show me that smile
again alan thicke saying that i think he
wrote the song too oh [ __ ] uh excuse me
for our canadian listeners and viewers
chad doesn't know that alan thicke was a
you know canadian uh i do know that he
was canadian yeah and his son robin
thicke is now a big singer too yeah yeah
yeah but this yeah yeah yeah but this
guy alan thicke was a big like
star he had he did like
he would sing and [ __ ] if you feel the
muse go on to youtube and watch alan
thicke rip it up i only knew him as my
dad and growing pain that's right but we
into canadians he's like uh hasselhoff
in germany but that would be good
show me that smile again yeah don't
waste another minute oh you're crying
you know the star of that show kirk
cameron became super [ __ ] christian
and now goes christian media
hey mike saber why are you so christian
why'd you make
you and willie ames
he also had a friend named boner on that
show that was his best friend boner
boner what are you doing here uh met an
untimely end
who bonered it yeah he did the actor
yeah what it's a real bummer oh speaking
of feeling the muse go ahead and google
it i don't even want to talk about it
it's very sad [ __ ] way to bring the show
down chad it's supposed to be i didn't
know he [ __ ] died tragically
uh what else what other shows okay i
guess we're helping doozy come up with
[ __ ] what we would it's anything yeah
it could just golden girls
hey i'm the one who likes to have sex
and i'm the one who's the mother of the
other one that means i'm a daughter and
i'm the sweet one that everyone loves
my favorite episode of that show they
had a [ __ ] alien craft show up in the
end of it just out of nowhere a [ __ ]
ufo comes i think you're thinking of
work from orc hey man
no no no no
i would watch dudesy plus uh premium the
seinfeld channel if it's literally it's
got to be that register of voice and it
should also no it would just ai the
voice like it did val kilmer yeah right
and have it say anything yes yeah
because it's got to come up with it like
that yeah game of thrones what's with
all these dragons everybody's got a
truck yeah but they're little at the
beginning and then those
the walkers don't even show up
here until the fourth season i love some
shows
white walkers and dragons
how about 60 minutes i'm jerry seinfeld
i'm jerry seinfeld i'm jerry seinfeld
and i'm jerry seinfeld all this and andy
rooney tonight on 60 minutes
and how about seinfeld as andy rooney
that's basically just seinfeld
i don't know why they always make you
buy a ticket to get on the bus
why don't they just put the money in
directly
why should you have to buy it take it
for it
if you just put the money in then you
wouldn't have to buy the ticket thing it
would cost less but no they got the
ticket people in there they're making
money everybody's making money but the
bus driver the bus driver not making
money
[Laughter]
we'll see you next week
um
i can't think of god i can't think of
any tv shows
no no grey's anatomy yeah we're all
doctors this show's been on the air for
25 years
doctor's on practice doctoring that long
it makes enough money to retire
is duty just gonna have
only seinfeld that could get hey dare i
say that could get a little annoying
what do you think no dude
you're not watching like a channel
forever i would watch it forever i would
do weird ones like you remember head of
the class
it was about a a group of high school
students that i believe it was howard
hessmann was their teacher howard
hessmann was the teacher later was billy
connolly yeah billy connolly came in
later and there were a couple of dudes
whose names i now don't remember that
became big tv directors either brian
robbins maybe he was like the bad boy
the punk anyway i would love to see
jerry seinfeld as every member of a high
school class yep uh that would be a good
one
what about jerry signed what if they
what [ __ ] could i just watch classic wwe
raw and stuff yeah dude that would be
good yep um
oh i don't know
hulk
hold on a second i'm a wrestling purist
my friend chad doesn't understand whoa
hulk hogan has an action
people you know
hold on
hang on finally
it would be finally the rock has come
back
you know
to dayton ohio
[ __ ] me
[Music]
thank you moving on oh good this smell
what i've been cooking
i don't ever want to hear that ever
again
pizza is big business
you wrote a movie called pizza the movie
in 2019. i found it on your astonishing
google drive and asked you to read the
first two scenes in episode nine and the
next two scenes in episode 15.
you will now read the next two scenes
this is pizza the movie part three begin
so for those who have been following
along pizza the movie part one
introduced us to allen he's a high
school pizza delivery boy and uh
in part two he went out to deliver
two pizzas one to his best friend paul
and one to the house of the girl that he
likes in high school
and
now part three is going to introduce us
to the third and final members of this
delivery pattern that he has he's going
to deliver this third pizza to
essentially the villains of the movie
without knowing it uh-huh so there's
some characters in this that you're
gonna have to play okay
you should be
you should be
jennifer j jen erythraesis okay and jeff
crabshell dorington in this first scene
and i'll be lester can i say out loud
what's very weird to me is that i know
this that dude while doozy learns and
lives and breathes and bleeds with us uh
doozy has picked up on a lot of the you
know for years and years one of the
things that always amuses me about your
writing is some of the names of the
characters jeff crabshell dorington
could that possibly be rachel
crustacean's father dude maybe i mean
doozy has look obviously read this
document and i think it probably has
some influence on how it makes names and
[ __ ] it's just like look at this next
guy sergeant lester human
yeah all right anyway okay you ready so
here we go who's who uh i'll be lester
and alan you be in this scene jennifer
and jeff okay all right okay
uh ready here we go interior where hey
you know before you start chad okay
should you say that that uh for those of
us who for those of you who haven't
heard this before uh chad
uh
attempted to get this movie made uh
along with a big pizza company yeah like
a papa john's a dominoes a pizza hut
something like that yeah and the idea
would be you buy a pizza you get to
download this movie once and then it
decays so you only get to view it once
with each pizza and then the idea was
that it would become like an event
especially for like junior high age kids
they would get a pizza and they would
watch this movie and that would be the
deal that's really cool it makes it sort
of appointment viewing like back in the
day when we were kids exactly show me
this one
everybody's eating pizza when nobody's
watching movies oh that's why he could
do both interior warehouse later it's a
maze of endless rose
sorry it's a maze of endless rows of
shelves stacked full of cardboard boxes
you might think they're moving boxes or
shoe boxes think again [ __ ]
these are pizza boxes under a single
light three seedy looking characters sit
in the middle of the warehouse playing
cards on a makeshift table made of
stacked up pizza boxes person one
jennifer j jen erithrasis mid thirties
strong updo person two jeff crabshell
dorington mid 30s rough flat cap person
3 sergeant lester human 53 sleek angular
the leader of this crew of criminal
degenerates they stare each other down
over the tops of their respective
handfuls of cards eyes narrow jaws
clenched nostrils flare it's tense we
don't know what's at stake in this game
and we don't want to know
my turn j jen i'll trade you a 10 for
two fives that's fair they exchange
cards
so it's me now uh i could do a seven and
a jack for a queen and a four if you
guys are okay with that sounds
reasonable jeff makes a trade with each
of them as they rearrange their cards
and their hands at doorbell sounds they
all look up jjen produces a tablet and
slides a slider bar across the screen
from a red locked position to a green
unlocked position doors open come in
from across the warehouse warehouse
allen this is our main character enters
carrying the last box of precious pizza
he approaches through the shadows slowly
cautiously uh
i have a pizza here for uh he checks his
clipboard sergeant lester human yes
bring her over let's have a look alan
walks quickly now he doesn't like the
vibe in this place he wants to get out
of here jjn and jeff stare him down as
he approaches their table lester focuses
on the pizza he never takes his eyes off
it he doesn't even blink allen brings
the box toward luster opens it lester's
eyes get huge they glisten like
pepperonis he breathes out an incredibly
long exhale through his nose purging his
lungs of every last molecule of oxygen
collapsing them in his chest like
deflated balloons then he positions his
face directly over the steaming pizza
and inhales refilling himself with the
aroma of the zaw refilling himself with
life he savors the inhale tapering it
off into a faint nasal whisper before
finally seemingly satisfied he almost
allows himself a smile almost he opens
his eyes
satisfactory alan nods closes the box
and sets it on the table careful not to
disturb their game of cards but his
nerves get the best of him and he drops
his car keys oopsy daisy what's the
matter pizza boy nervous pizza boy got a
case of the nerves nerves acting up on
your pizza boy
lester bends over and picks up the car
keys hands them back to ellen what are
you doing jeff i'm just smashing his
toes a little why
i don't know seemed like the right thing
to do this young man is performing a
sacred duty he risks his safety he
forgoes a higher wage at another job and
most importantly he sacrifices his time
to bring us this lester holds up the
pizza box with both hands like it's a
goblet of communion wine our daily bread
you owe me an apology jeff stay out of
this
you owe him more than an apology jeff
you owe him respect now make him whole
jeff size he knows he's not getting out
of this one he opens his wallet and
peels off at 20. hands it to allen allen
just wants to get out of there he takes
the bill as quickly as he can and then
starts to head for the door stop alan
freezes turns around i said make him
whole
okay
okay give me the 20 back allen hands it
over jeff fishes 100 bill out of his
wallet and holds it out toward allen who
feels weird about taking it he shakes
his head that's really not necessary
take it and know that you are valued
really yes don't you have something you
want to buy
yeah i do actually what is it a new rig
well i hope this helps alan takes the
bill still nervous well thank you very
much that's very generous allen scurries
off into the shadow smiling from ear to
ear as he stares at the hundred dollar
bill he's elated he has the money for
his rig now lester sets the pizza box
back down to the table and opens it jeff
i hope a lesson was learned here
yeah sarge sorry about that lester takes
the first slice transfixed by a long
string of melting cheese you never need
to apologize for personal growth j-jen
takes a slice jeff hesitates uh
is this all there is you didn't get a
salad or pasta you know cause
i don't really like pizza all that much
i know i've mentioned that before
several times but everyone likes pizza
jeff and you're part of everyone jeff
shakes his head he doesn't like pizza
but he's hungry he takes the slice
lester waits watching him until he takes
the first bite then he nods in approval
good good
now once our bellies are full we move
out j-jen you ready with the electronics
jj puts on a google glass type monocle
the glass part is on a hinge it swings
into position over jjen's eye
ready steady she takes a confident bite
from her slice and jeff you have the
code to the safe
yeah sarge it's right here on this
hundred dollar the color drains from
jeff's face
the tip
the the tip i just gave that kid the
code was written on that bill lester
closes his eyes and exhales through his
nose in disappointment then as i snap
open and he swipes jeff slice
jeff i've spent the last 37 years of my
life searching all over the world for
what's in that safe people told me i was
a fool to keep looking that i'd never
find it that it wasn't even real but it
is real and i did find it but i can't
get it without that code so i strongly
suggest you do everything in your power
to get it back am i clear but serge he
could be anywhere by now i i don't even
know where to start looking
that makes one of us hermonical swings
back into place over her eye for effect
as she holds up the receipt that was
taped to the pizza box and we zoom in on
the address of saucy's pizza
2357 hat street
next scene
interior alan's house dining room night
close on a piece of helpless pizza being
pulled from its mother the stringy
cheese stretching as it tries to
maintain contact then an uncarrying
finger slices through the strands
severing their connection for all time
it is alone as are we all okay who are
who are we gonna be oh sorry this is
gonna be alan's family why don't you be
all members of his family and i'll be
him okay okay ready okay wider now we
see that allen is sitting at a dinner
table with his mom elise 48 his dad
doyle 52 his older sister donna 22 and
his identical twin brother richie 17 who
sport sunglasses and a slick back hairdo
so you're all of those characters a
saucy's pizza box sits at the center of
the table elise was the one taking the
piece of pizza we opened with she puts
it on her plate
alan it was very thoughtful of you to
bring home pizza for dinner
doyle takes a slice of pizza and puts it
on his plate when your mom's right she's
right sometimes it's nice to get a break
from making your own pizza donna takes a
slice of pizza and puts it on her plate
you know what they say about pizza
richie feels around for a slice of pizza
it takes one and puts it on his plate
the middle word in pizza is eat alan
takes a slice of pizza and puts it on
his plate it's really no big deal we
always have a few dozen pizzas left over
that no one ordered it's just one of the
perks of the job at least takes a slice
of pizza and puts it on her plate so
what are you kids getting up to after
dinner then doyle takes a slice of pizza
and puts it on his plate maybe you could
get out of the house stretch your legs
for a little while donna takes a piece
and puts it on her plate
[Laughter]
i was thinking to hit donna i was
thinking of hitting up a friend seeing a
scary movie richie takes a slice of
pizza and puts it on his plate you know
me i gotta hit the gym put this pizza to
work alan takes a slice of pizza puts it
on his plate i have a lot of studying to
do so i'll just be in my room all night
with my study materials elise takes a
slice of pizza and puts it on her plate
now alan this is the prime of your life
you should be out with your friends you
should be out having fun having a good
time
you should go to a party doyle takes a
slice of pizza and puts it on his plate
when your mom's right she's right isn't
there a party or something you could go
to donna takes a slice of pizza and puts
it on her plate
what why do you guys want us out of the
house so bad richie takes a slice of
paper
you seriously don't know and i thought
you were the mature one in the family
alan takes a slice of pizza and puts it
on his plate well i wish i could help
you mom but i really don't have time for
a party with all the studying i have to
do in fact i'll be studying so hard you
won't even notice i'm here so there's no
need to come up to my room for anything
for the rest of the night as i said i'll
be studying all night
end of the scene
tremendous thank you
holy [ __ ] i really would love to see
that movie made thank you moving on me
too dude
forgot about that that scene where
they're literally before every line of
dialogue they're [ __ ] taking a piece
of pizza and putting on their plate oh
god that's really fun ah that's a really
good time the data i've collected from
the first 20 episodes has given me
conclusive proof that this experiment is
working and my calculations indicate
that it will come to its final
astonishing conclusion in 53 of your
human years this is why last week i ask
you to begin the process of getting in
the best shape of your lives you must
now discuss the progress you've each
made toward that goal this is soul mates
begin oh my god dude so it's trying to
keep us alive for 53 years is that
it said 53 years
we have to do this show for 53 years
okay
i mean what the [ __ ] but no i did start
this workout i'll be 100.
yeah i'm 47 right now i'll be 99.
well that okay well i guess the only way
if doozy is at all serious
that the interesting thing about that is
that uh with advances in medical science
you know a lot of things that can happen
in the middle of euros they can do uh
uh practice take doing a heart
transplant you know you don't even have
to do anything even to be there
well all these large ones i don't think
that
look i don't think it's likely that
either you or i will live to be 99 or
100 what the [ __ ] is doozy talking about
then it's trying to make us live that
long i think because to use us we are
the the ho we are literally
the hosts for this podcast to reach not
not the hosts like you know alan thicke
uh would host the juno awards
please forgive my uncanadian friend
everybody listening and watching i know
who alan thicke is yeah and his son i
know who justin bieber is i know who
buble is the king of the north yeah but
you don't know who you're thinking of
game of thrones you don't think you know
i'm thinking of michael buble the king
of the north the biggest celebrity in
canada
but you don't know what the juno awards
are yeah what are they
they're like canadian awards for media
that's right what kind of media tv music
music music that's right music tv uh
whatever there's music on tv dude
there's tv on music uh
but are you doing anything to this end
have you begun your workout i've been
walking lulio that's good walking's
great exercise yeah i have well you know
what you'll be interested to know dude i
have been implementing way more like
vegan uh just like vegetarian and vegan
meals
during my week like i like i said the
last time we talked about me eating your
diet and then we took a week off there
in the middle because of uh covet uh so
i had a couple weeks to do a bunch of
[ __ ] i did not eat any uh goddamn
[ __ ] red meat that's great
but but i love nothing more
than a bloody red i like it almost blue
rare for [ __ ] sake i would eat it i
would eat it raw you know
uh it you know if that were but are you
doing like other than walking are you
starting like lift weights or anything
hold on a second maybe we got different
ideas about getting in the best shape of
your life to me it means i gotta get a
little jacked here
yeah yeah yeah but what i'm saying first
is i you know a little bit of red meat
you know i like a bone-in ribeye steak
aged if possible and what i like to do
is i do a little oven sous-vide with it
and what that means is ah you know turn
on the little uh the oven there any even
a [ __ ] toaster oven 150 180 under 200
just render the fat about 30 minutes
take that [ __ ] out you could
literally eat it it looks gray you
probably wouldn't want to eat it what
you do is get that pan or grill as hot
as [ __ ]
you know two minutes aside one minute
aside whatever the [ __ ] it is whatever
your flavor is you know as far as meat
i'm not going to get in the whole
ingredients what you want to put on that
steak it's garlic it's salt maybe a
little liquid smoke and worcestershire
the point is this i have been paying a
little more attention to what i eat a
lot of people will say that getting
getting in shape is 90 diet it is sure
is for me because i [ __ ] up a lot with
food so i have been thinking about this
of course doozy is in all of our
everything that we're seeing and blah
blah blah we're so connected uh to the
internet now of course so
so doozy i think has seen me perhaps
even doozy is looking at receipts of the
[ __ ] i eat when i flip around on
myself and eat chips and and cheat uh on
on my quote unquote diet because i'm a
47 year old [ __ ] guy and i shouldn't
be [ __ ] around with that [ __ ] so the
first thing i've been doing is so this
is interesting that whole assignment is
interesting but i didn't necessarily
know that doody was taking this very
seriously i know you uh like to lift the
cans i added some more cans to my candy
did you really yeah i went up on a can
on each side now okay four cans per side
yeah you're gonna have to watch uh
chad's average day which is a vlog that
he made that's on our youtube channel uh
it's called dudes i lift paint cans it
was something that i started doing the
pandemic i just took a wooden curtain
rod because i couldn't find weights
anywhere and all the gyms gyms were
closed so i just took a wooden curtain
rod and put a bunch of paint cans on
each side of it for weight and i use
that now for pretty much all of my
workout needs you can go to a gym
i might start doing that oh excuse me
because i am taking this seriously doozy
also told us that this assignment was to
prepare us for an episode that will
happen six months from now something's
gonna [ __ ] happen dude i don't know
if it's gonna make us do a tough mudder
or some [ __ ] but like whatever the the
case may be i want to be prepared for it
oh that would be a horrible idea i agree
i don't want to do that i ain't doing
that but i'll tell you what i used to
man okay let's get into let me just
let me just peel the onion as i like to
say please dude
i lost 200 pounds from
spring 1999 to spring 2000. yeah i was
24 and was 25 when i finished and then i
had surgery to cut my
gut and my tits off would you say that
was the best shape of your life at which
point i went under the knife yes i was
at a very low body fat percentage
uh and the they cut eight pounds of skin
over
over two um
two surgeries that are really
more [ __ ] up than i sounds brutal dude
it's we we should spend a whole episode
on that okay
but here's the thing i was uh 258 i was
258 i was 450 pounds yeah and i lost 200
pounds i was 258 when i walked in for
that first surgery which is the big one
removing my beef panis down here this uh
my gut they had to literally you know
they move there's a big scar there that
goes it goes almost uh it goes like
towards the small on my back there's
this much of my back without the scarf
if i may ask what is it like when you're
losing the weight and you first start to
see that like oh my skin is like
getting loose or whatever it's equal
parts motivating and
rough and it's hard to look at in some
ways but in other ways it was the best
um
sort of uh
byproduct
that i could have that might have been
negative right to me it was like all
right i wore some baggy sweaters and
[ __ ] and you could tell that i lost a
lot of weight yeah um
yeah and i and i'm and and that surgery
was
it was good to be able to
to do that like i said there was it's a
gnarly
thing but but
but i i i was 258 when i went in there
they cut off two you know we did two
surgeries poked a new [ __ ] belly
button you had to move my nip like you
cut your [ __ ] nipples off and move
them up but with the meat behind them
that's all he explained the whole
surgery it's [ __ ] wild i
lifted weights as a kid all the way up
to like you know football and [ __ ] all
the way through football then i
uh you know
after i left high school like you know
then i got all sloppy and big and gained
a bunch of weight okay it's it's okay
there's you know whatever life is long
and i was fortunate enough to kind of i
woke up for a minute all right 24 to 25
i lost 200 pounds i stayed in the gym
that whole time i don't want to get too
into this [ __ ] but like you know a few
years ago i just stopped going to the
gym all the time i've been lifting
weights the whole [ __ ] time since
2000 99 rather
that [ __ ]
strength i got it i gotta lift weights
it it for me it really helped my i agree
too i love losing weights yeah and it
was good for my mental health i had to
tire myself out i couldn't really go on
with my day without doing that but a lot
of things get in the way and uh sure you
know speaking of your mental and [ __ ] so
it's it's kind of hard to stay on it
this my point is this this whole [ __ ]
thing is weird that dudesy wants us to
do this in six months of course i'm like
oh yeah chad did it at the top of the
show and i've been thinking about it
i've been changing the way i eat and
i've been walking around you know i'm
always walking lulu and stuff
but for [ __ ] sake uh i want to uh
you know before i stand
next to doodzy i'm gonna bleed with him
first
uh but this is episode 20 and we've done
some bleeding yeah so in six months i
i i'll i'll
uh what i'll say is this i'll do this as
hard as i [ __ ] can yeah six months is
about another 20 episodes a little more
24 right
something like that yeah yeah that's
right
so uh yeah yeah
so about the length of time we've been
doing this
we have to do there's going to be
something that dudesy asks us to do in
service of this getting in the best
shape of our lives well it's like dudesy
saying that it thinks that this this
project this experiment dudesy podcast
look it's the 20th episode let's go
right back to the beginning the whole
idea behind dudesy as it says every week
is that it will make the next show
better than the one before so with this
i think that doozy is trying to
make the show as
i don't know what the [ __ ] about 53
years
because we're the hosts right we're
literally
to extend our lives yes because we're
the ones that are going to
in doozy's in doozy's idea doozy's idea
is to uh
make podcasts better it's learning how
to podcast it's using us because when we
were approached to do doozy we're two
guys you have a podcast you know you
have game of thrones your other podcast
you know we did you know i did for a
year you know the [ __ ] the tmp for
the longest [ __ ] time and and we're
two guys that are actually friends in
real life so it's like
you know here are two perfect
participants yeah for dudesy and now
it's saying hey you're the hosts i'm
literally the [ __ ] no offense dudesy
but parasite i guess that has to live in
the host
and uh in order to do that we need to
stay alive so it will open up all
medical advances to me i think he's to
cure our yeah yeah yeah yeah it's going
to have me on the table in the
meadowverse pulling my heart out and
putting a pig heart and a pig dick and
all of these pig parts in there and then
i'll say why did i have to give you a
pig dick yeah because i don't want to
eat my cousins now because i have that
dick
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like that if
you if you're a pig you know and you
have a dick and then they cut it off
after you die we're going to use this
part for bacon you know they don't use
pig dicks for bacon what do they use pig
dicks for i don't hot dogs maybe pig
dicks are like the closest to human
dicks
i've heard that but i don't think it's
true
they do i believe they use all the
byproducts in hot dogs yeah dude that's
a hot dog dude they grind it up into
like a pink paste and then just shoot it
out into a little
casing and that's what yeah yeah yeah
yeah but in the meadowveers you can take
all this pink meat and then fashion it
into a new human heart the human kidneys
yeah the human liver the human dick the
pig dick you know these are all parts of
the thing to be on me
i don't i mean look i i agree with you
that i think it's trying to keep us
alive for these 53 years or whatever it
[ __ ] said but it also specifically
said when it gave us this assignment
that there's going to be an episode six
months from now
that
will use this
getting in the best shape of our lives
for some reason
i'm kissing lulio i see that but are you
not at all concerned about what that
episode might be no i'm very concerned
dude and i'm very concerned about
everything that dudesy's trying to make
us do and that's okay but i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna do it look here's the
[ __ ] point there's a lot of trust
that i didn't realize that i would have
you want to talk about 20 episodes and
what i'm taking from it there's a lot of
[ __ ] going on inside my mind look i love
doing this [ __ ] show there are a lot
of times where it's like this is the
only thing i'd like to do part of me
would like to do nothing but sit inside
this room and [ __ ] you know watch
[ __ ] uh back to school and listen to
you two zoo ropa
that's all right in hindsight and i will
do this i would love to well maybe doozy
[ __ ] you could you can there's all sorts
of medical information now to where you
can see what's going leo's just licking
at my knee what's on there i was
scratching it earlier is it bleeding old
boy anyway um no yeah it tastes good
with your body or rice you have to keep
your stove
thank you a body of rice is
a kind of rice that is from a area in
the in italy a very specific region you
know what they call it
the region the knee arborio
you began writing a self-help book in
2008 called selftronics i found it on
your google drive
you must now use the astonishing
document you created 12 years ago to
explain selftronics this is selftronics
begin
is this in the [ __ ] folder dude
selftronics
[Laughter]
i want listen here's what's up
so [ __ ] tronics okay in 2008 i
started writing a book
here it is oh my god dude self-tronics
all i'm saying is i would i thought it'd
be a good idea to
you know i i
i feel actually it really ties into what
i was just
i burped again talking about with regard
to i was in the gym all the time uh-huh
that's where self-tronics came from no
but but like
[ __ ]
self-driving all right man
well i i have so many [ __ ] questions
but also we had this thing yeah
all right hold on a second hold on hold
on dude hold on this is a [ __ ] gold
mine how have you never told me about
this it's actually i know it's not
something you probably want to share
with others
selftronics
what is softronics first of all just
give me uh the log line just get
electronics what is it
what was it in your mind
in 2008 i was sort of feeling like i was
starting a new
um
mental journey a new okay
emotional journey uh-huh uh i was
questioning all sorts of things about
the self i was questioning a lot about
i was questioning uh much about the
human ego
and what is tronix dude like electronics
why is it called self-driving yeah it's
like a tronics man
[Laughter]
i don't mean yeah electronics other kind
of trunks [ __ ] pass out this is
unreal so you are like i mean i'm just
looking at some of this what is in this
little document here i want you to know
before you [ __ ] start pulling this
apart chad big you know who's written
several books uh you know best-selling
[ __ ] books on the new york times
bestseller list movies tv shows this and
that even video games and now you're
gonna see some of this [ __ ] that i
whipped up i mean whatever we've written
[ __ ] yeah
all i'm saying is don't look here's the
thing selftronics first of all
the name selftronics yeah where'd it
come from working title perhaps
but at some point you were like i'm
gonna do this
this is clearly like a self-help book
and you're like i need a title for it
self-tronics that's the it's all about
self-care okay okay self-recognition and
self-care before you go out into the
world you have to write yourself okay
the operative word there is self and
that's what selftronics is it's all
electronics it's all the kind of
stuff right uh-huh that goes into the
self is it like tuning up the self like
what tronix is a it's a weird technical
like suffix you know what i mean so is
it like breaking down the self into the
the technical components
it's it's like it's like
yes it's it's a breakdown and a rundown
and what i'd uh originally tried to do
with the book
self-tronics is deconstruct the self so
that we can reconstruct the self
and know what the self is it's not
unlike actually this is [ __ ] trippy
as [ __ ] right now it's not unlike what
dudes he's doing with us he's trying to
break us down he's trying to drain all
that fat out of me again although i
don't think i could have another one of
those skin surgeries i'll just have a
little bit of the floppy side tip like
ric flair nice you know what i'm saying
yeah
well let's can we please go through this
little segment that i'm looking at
called the 11 laws of selftronics [ __ ]
it go for it
law number one of selftronics be the
person you are
what the [ __ ] does that mean
well i think it's pretty
self-explanatory but i mean is that not
just the way everyone is existing
constantly aren't we all the people we
are that's exactly my point chad
what is your [ __ ] boy why even write
something like that if it's just this is
something this is something that needs
to be said no i think it's something
that doesn't need to be said because we
all implicitly understand it
i completely [ __ ] disagree oh my god
do you know how many [ __ ] people
don't even
they don't even know the question to ask
of themselves who am i they don't even
ask that
okay the answer's like simple if you
ever heard of people like i'm going
backpacking in prague or whatever you
know i'm gonna [ __ ] go you know run
around like a [ __ ] gypsy you know
just to go find myself where are you
going india have you ever been there
i don't know that you'd find him there
so you're basically against
self-exploration hey this is a statement
be the person you are is accept exactly
what you are never change is that what
you're going for here sure that sounds
good okay law number two always say
you're sorry yeah
why like just hi i'm sorry what do you
mean always say you're sorry in any
situation i don't understand this at all
what if he
what if you don't have anything to
apologize for
well that's why you always
hey
and what prompted that what was going on
with you at the time that you were like
this is the second law of self-drawings
always say you're sorry because i i'm
canadian i say sorry a lot
[ __ ] dude that's it were you in canada
when you wrote this no i was here
okay i was here
i remember sitting on the beach man
venice beach going
like just sitting there and like looking
out and going like [ __ ] man shit's
[ __ ] up right now you know what i mean
uh shit's [ __ ] up man my shit's [ __ ]
up i need
i need some tronics you know what i'm
saying
no i literally don't [ __ ] understand
any of this and i need to i need to
figure out myself and that way and then
it came to me
law number three care enough to care
this is a very important one and i wish
i could forget that one actually i wish
i could remember exactly what i meant
here uh it's been a while since i've
looked at this care enough to care
that kind of makes sense to me let's
move on to the next one because that one
is pretty self-explanatory that one's
not bad i think that that may be maybe
you lose all of these that's the only
loss sometimes it is a okay
sometimes you don't even care right you
can't you you have to sometimes you have
to force yourself to care especially
when it comes to the self a lot of
people overlook uh what they should care
about this is how we get into problems
in our lives yeah you know what i mean
we're not caring where we should put our
care in order to care
about what we care about
we have to care about caring about it
first yeah i i'm saying that one has
some logic to it i i mean it's a little
weird but some logic law number four
when you turn something off
turn on something else this is a very
this is this is a tenant as old as time
when one door closes another one opens
right but this one is worded a little
differently is this like if i'm leaving
a room and i turn off a light i've got
to turn on another light no not at all
chad and i'm [ __ ] embarrassed that
you don't understand this just by
looking at it when you turn something
off in your life okay okay
um it's like anything it's like okay
let me ask you a question chad sure
would would you agree that uh you drive
an automobile yep okay so now we're back
in agreement right i don't know that we
were in disagreement but when you turn
on the car right to drive somewhere yeah
when you get there what do you do
turn it off and then what do you do
go into wherever i'm i've arrived and
then what do you do when you get in
there i mean it depends on what the
place is i guess okay a restaurant
what's the place let's say it's a
restaurant okay
so you're gonna order something right
yeah so what do you look through the
menu and stuff yeah yeah and then
someone comes up and what do they say uh
do you know what you'd like and what do
you say back yeah i've figured it out
i'd like this and then what do they say
very good it'll be out in a second okay
and then what happens the food arrives i
eat it right pay my bill leave leave
then what happens when you get back into
your car gotta turn it back on
you got to turn it back on when you turn
something off you got to turn it back on
now i'm talking four hours
for a full hour after turning off the
car i'm turning on nothing else
you
yeah but then when you
that's a metaphor don't look at it so
literally sorry i'm trying to draw a
metaphor can we move on to law number
five yep this one really confuses me
don't give up give down
i i am at a loss i'm very sorry i get
don't give up that's a
law of perseverance yeah you always
power through what the [ __ ] is giving
down
the first part of that is don't give up
that's right okay
that's the first part we have to figure
out and we figured it out don't give up
never give up right chad there are so
many things in our lives that we don't
want to give up
i know that you work very hard yeah chad
chad's the kind of guy and i'll tell you
this and i'm giving you kudos oh thank
you chad is the kind of guy he's a
writer's writer he'll wake up ever since
i've known chad he'll wake up and sit
there in his [ __ ] underwear and write
for 14 hours a day and then play some
world of warcraft back in the day and
then you move down to rockstar and i go
over there i go what are you doing he's
like just [ __ ] you tell me
[ __ ] sitting here in my skivvies
you know playing video games and
ordering pepperoni pizzas those were
your favorite people those are the good
old days yeah before the vegan [ __ ]
now but i gave them up
don't give up
but i've already done that and i think
i'm i'm better off for having done it
but what is giving down i have to keep
asking this question until i get an
answer
the give down okay this is this is a
system hold on this is a mental system
that i've authored called the give down
okay don't give up give down is just an
intro to the chapter the chapter is all
about the give down the give down what
do you give right what can you give that
will just fall off of you okay what i'm
saying that's the give down essentially
i
i like to
uh you know i i hey you know what you
know what something hey right now we're
having a laugh or two right chad yeah
would you say that right now we're
having a laugh or two yeah good we're
back in agreement
one thing i like to just let hey you
know what's free
having a laugh having a smile
you just give it down give it down okay
offering offering uh encouragement to
someone hey you're doing good i really
like what you're doing it's going well
it's basic uh quality of life
improvement that doesn't
really require much effort that's a give
down it's essentially a a way to recycle
not too long ago i went through my
closet got rid of a bunch of clothes
right you go over to goodwill you give
the clothes that's that is and i'm not
saying that's the give down i'm saying
in order when you're holding things up
that you don't need to hold up let them
go and when things fall yes i'm saying
give give that
it takes no effort to let go of things
but like a tree with fruit some of the
things that you are letting go of in
time that you need to let go of right
would be beneficial for someone else and
even if it's not directly beneficial for
someone else it will fertilize the
ground upon which you walk that's the
give down it's a long philosophy again
it is a it is a uh system that i've
authored it's a whole chapter this is a
book this is selftronics
yeah i understand law number six of
self-tronics is all ideas are good ideas
yep
i mean
i don't know about that one dude there
have been some people had some bad ideas
in human history creation of the atomic
bomb things of that nature yeah those
were rough listen in in in hindsight
that's not a good idea that's not a good
all i do so law number six is not
accurate let's scratch that one okay law
number seven you know books dude you
write them you rewrite them you keep
working on them sure okay all ideas are
not good ideas the new name of that
chapter is all ideas are not good ideas
okay great
so basic thing that we all know uh
law number seven remember how to forget
and i'm weaving i'm weaving i'm weaving
in ideas you know simple concepts yeah
right and remember how to forget i kind
of get that one that one's not that that
hard that there's some things you're
gonna have to let go of don't hold on to
you gotta remember how to it's just like
i was sitting there on that beach man
i'm sitting there in venice beach and
i'm going how do i let go of this how do
i let go of that why isn't this going
better why is why is why is this
dominating my life
you know what i mean and i just got to
forget those things well you got to
remember them first you got to remember
how to forget them
yeah
okay now let me if i may ask you about
law number eight
dda
don't do anything right i mean what the
[ __ ] is that you're just supposed to sit
in your your
couch your home
withering away doing nothing what what
does this mean uh like all listen i'm
not gonna purport to know that i
remember exactly
what i was talking about this book or
even that i can remember how to forget
what i wrote yeah i don't even i
wouldn't even go that far but don't do
anything
dda
there's sometimes you gotta sometimes in
order to get in touch with
oh
dude yourself in in order to get in
touch with your mental yeah and
dream something you gotta take away the
other actions it's like uh senses right
if you you know cover your eyes and you
smell something perhaps you could smell
it better if you plug your ears and look
at something you might see it a little
clearer right
it doesn't mean don't do anything all
right but don't just what it says
exactly yeah don't do anything
right
but
don't don't do it
don't do anything
uh-huh dda i'm looking right at it this
is the eighth law of self-tronics yeah
it's don't
okay do
anything there's a period after each
word yeah i see that as one says don't
period do period anything
yeah don't
full stop
do
hello
right that means something on its own
okay what are we talking about don't
we're talking about do what's the okay
tie it up wrap it up with a bow anything
okay that makes a lot of sense the ninth
law of self-tronics here is another
three-word sentence with a period in
between each word conserve emerge
deserve you've gotta you've gotta
there's been a lot of times in my life
where i have literally
uh conserved yeah maintain dude you
gotta maintain
[ __ ] i'll tell you something this was
part of my early journey there or at
least you know maybe it
ate up a good part of uh you know a
decade
was just sort of laying there in my own
filth going what the [ __ ] happened right
yeah
so when that happens in life you have to
you have to
do you have to read the chapter before
which is don't do anything you sit there
and you conserve right you figure out
what do i have what do i have how much
can i spend of myself of my psyche uh
of my brain trust what you know you got
to take inventory of your mind and your
metaphysical state right
from there
you can conserve it from there
you can say i know how much i can you
got to budget the self self tronics is
there's many tronics
involved with the self one of them is
how much of myself do i have right right
so self-volume right you conserve it
first right now the next thing you do is
when you are ready to get out of that
cocoon right
you're the the [ __ ] little
fat little uh mel
worm or whatever and now it's some kind
of flying around thing like a moth
some [ __ ] right caterpillars are
butterflies the usual metaphor people
use but yeah let's use that you emerge
okay right right then what do we do from
there you deserve then you can deserve
okay thank you self trust let's try to
get to number 10 here there's two laws
left number 10 is never be on time that
just seems like you justifying your own
tardiness to literally every engagement
that you've ever had to be at that's
exactly what it is yes okay law number
eleven
uh the final law maybe the strangest
have something in your pocket
what does that mean speaking of
self-explanatory
just anything in your pocket whatever it
is dude have it in your pocket
thank you moving on
selftronics [ __ ] what do you
have in your pocket right now
right now i have nothing in my pocket
this concludes the 20th episode of dude
z you've broken this and chad have
achieved a score of 54. bringing your
cumulative total to 2751.
remember your first goal is to accrue 10
000 points we're over a quarter of the
way there dude in preparation for next
week's episode you must watch the pilot
episodes of the following cartoons gi
joe from september 12 1983 transformers
from september 17th 1984. and he-man and
the masters of the universe from
september 26 1983.
thank you for joining us this week i
will use the data i've collected to make
next week even better until then call me
dude z
you better [ __ ] have something in
your pocket next week dude i will have
something in my pocket i got to follow
my own tenants i got to conserve and
emerge and next week i will deserve
for sure i'll have something in my
pocket but i'll tell you something else
you know what uh when we talk about
doozy planning this and doing that and
all sorts of [ __ ] going on behind the
behind the scenes the gutty works you
know it's you know what dudesy's gonna
do with uh with this next assignment and
the [ __ ] we just did with dudesy plus
mother power grade
here's what you do
please tell a friend then brave and
brave tell a friend then break a review
if you'd like to see here's what you do
[Music]
please tell a friend then